my aunt actually took me in when I uh
when I uh ran away I ran away wasn't a
lot so yeah dude it was a prophecy well
no no I ran away years later I ran away
when I was like [ __ ] 21. that's not
running away
hold on you ran away at 21. yeah I got
robbed and then
there's a lot going on a lot going on
[Laughter]
bro how do you run away that's the
whitest [ __ ] I've ever heard how you run
away from 21 years Mom I'm leaving good
I'm ready honestly
tell this story I say I ran away when
like like from like my city like I left
Atlanta and I went to DC and I told my
Aunt I was like I'm gonna live with you
and I'm just gonna like figure out a job
situation up here you know whatever
figure it all out and then you know she
let me come and I was just grown as [ __ ]
living in her crib you know what I'm
saying with my cousins and [ __ ] and they
were like yeah she deserves she deserves
how did you get robbed what happened you
got robbed it's just some [ __ ] man
like you know Atlanta's a crazy place
you guys might not know about it man but
[ __ ] happens [ __ ] transpires all the
time like crying when he robbed you what
the [ __ ]
this is a show where we take I mean
journalism seriously bro come on so why
was I wasn't crying
yeah yeah why was his big ass crying
[Laughter]
no honestly honestly thank you you're
great honestly the the that [ __ ]
was crying because he kept continuously
saying like I don't want to do this to
y'all I I really wanted your homeboy and
I was like yo I can get you to my home
I can get you to him as fast as [ __ ]
possible if you need his number you need
it where he stays I will get you to him
but you know there's just some that
whole situation was crazy as Funk he
robbed you at your home he arrives yeah
he robbed me at uh an apartment we were
all me and all my boys were standing at
the time and uh yeah we were all shook
as [ __ ] came in but he started crying
yeah he is yeah so he broke down the
door uh not necessarily broke down the
door we we seen him it was all it all
happened in the car like he was outside
the car we were in the car oh I didn't
pull off though
stupid move what do you mean that's
scary though you guys are getting robbed
hit the [ __ ] pedal oh you were
driving pedal to the metal
but I do nah you probably thinking he
pulled the you know what I mean he can't
see he's crying
yeah 100 yeah gun is in your face he
went to driver's side whoa what type of
gun
why the [ __ ] would I know that that's it
it's a lot to remember I mean yeah it's
like super Barrel
oh glove nine actually no he had a
[ __ ] gun ah doesn't everybody down
south have guns and [ __ ] don't you know
about all that it's a handgun a handgun
there you go it wasn't like an AKA
yeah
yeah that's some [ __ ] should it be a
Rob in a car with a machete that's not
[ __ ] though if you got robbed when the
guy hasn't shut that off when you pull
off if he has him in the car yeah if it
stalls
wait a machete is Like a Knife right
yeah the car
[Laughter]
what did he get
um he got a couple hundred for me I was
begging like I was giving him anything
but he didn't really want it from us
like he really wanted
our homeboy and he was like yo I'm sorry
that this is happening to y'all but I
really want him and I'm like bro I will
[ __ ] take you there
like I really was volunteering to take
him but you know
I was ready to snitch for sure yeah oh
this is actually this is your life yeah
that's your life now this is a good
question can you hold on yeah yeah no
y'all snitching are we gonna go down the
line yeah let's go are you giving up
your homeboy where he's at if somebody
has a gun to you understand just take me
there I want to know where he's at I'm
gonna lie and say I'm taking them there
and then I'm just gonna drive to the
precinct I'm not gonna actually take
them to Mom he's home he's gonna blow
your [ __ ] black ass head off
oh yeah I grew up Catholic I go to
confession I'm gonna snitch hundred
percent a boy got you what's your answer
I'll snitch [ __ ] out of here
wait wait wait hold on hold on hold on
hold on what's the reason what like what
what you gonna do because snitches do
dish what is it alone
what are you doing no so you tell us
what you're doing in that system what
would I do in that situation yeah pull
the trigger [ __ ] boy all right boom
you're dead nah you're done well no if
he kills me you're never gonna know
where my friend is but I'm gonna take
your [ __ ] Dead non-religious Guy go
ahead I don't even go nowhere lie to
this person how is he a good friend he's
a good friend I would never snitch on
this guy I'll snitch on them too no
problem
a lot of people like actually think out
the scenario like how we're doing now
but honestly when you're in it you're
snatching bro you don't even [ __ ]
think I would have drove away like I
wouldn't just you can't even drive away
drive away
like talk to me or something
did you say that did I say that no no no
I was [ __ ] panicking trying to get
directions to the GPS of where we needed
to go
[Music]
for me bro like I'll get you whatever
right now so what's it Justified of what
your friend did to him
ah because maybe that changes well yeah
was it like payback yeah
honestly I really I really don't know
what he wanted for that guy but like you
know I guess they had a past relation
that
they had something going on for them you
know it is politically correct that's
all right
what are you gonna do is go to your
friend be like yo what the [ __ ]
yeah
how do you how do you get out of that
scenario your idea is pretty good you're
gonna drive in there you go drive right
to the precinct he's not gonna do
anything at the precinct
brilliant thinking in the moment but
he's not gonna let you go you know where
the precinct is off the top of your head
no I'm saying in your hood like if
you're in your town you know what a
[ __ ] priest since I grew up in
Gwinnett County man you don't know where
the [ __ ] is
he's low-key right though
I don't know where the precinct is I got
no idea in New York
no but that [ __ ] mattered in the
elections I remember they kept talking
about Gwinnett County yeah